après l'assemblée le sénat a adopté
cette nuit le projet de réforme de la
constitution par 171 voix contre 112
on attend maintenant la décision du
président de la république à propos du
congrès de versailles combat acharné ce
matin sur le golan et sur les deux rives
du canal de suez
le général moshe derrière n'a traversé
le canal monsieur kossyguine est rentré
à moscou
dénouement sanglant de la sphère de
beyrouth il ya une heure à peine
l'armée et la police ont investi la
banque de l'amérique libérant une
soixantaine d'otages et tuant plusieurs
terroristes
l'airbus de retour en france après avoir
été présenté pendant un mois aux
américains du nord et du sud
l'airbus a parcouru une distance
équivalent au tour du monde pour la
première fois six voitures quatre
françaises et deux étrangères soumise à
un banc d'essai draconien par l'institut
national de la consommation
à quelques jours de la semaine du coeur
73 notre magazine consacré à cet
important problème avec sur notre
plateau l'un des plus éminents
cardiologues français le professeur
michel deux genres mais à mesdemoiselles
messieurs bonjour les deux premiers
titres de ce journal démontre bien que
l'actualité parlementaire demeure très
intense avec quant à faire que constitue
la réforme constitutionnelle et la loi
royer
pour ce qui concerne la loi royer sur le
commerce et l'artisanat
la discussion va se poursuivre
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale les
parlementaires doivent en effet se
pencher à nouveau notamment sur
l'article 23 qui concerne la composition
des commissions d'urbanisme pour
l'implantation des magasins à grande
surface
pour ce qui est de la réforme de la
constitution le sénat tout comme l'avait
fait l'assemblée a adopté cette nuit ce
projet le sénat l'a adopté sans
amendement par 171 voix contre 112 dès
lors que ce texte de révision de la
constitution a été adopté par les deux
assemblées à la majorité simple
on se pose maintenant la question de
savoir si le président de la république
convoquera le congrès c'est-à-dire
l'assemblée le sénat réunis ou le projet
pour être définitivement adoptée doit
l'être par la majorité des trois
cinquièmes un rapide calcul démontre
qu'en additionnant les suffrages
exprimés au sénat et à l'assemblée
il manque une vingtaine de voix pour que
ce projet soit adopté par le congrès
avec une majorité des trois cinquièmes
alors une question que va décider le
président pompidou
le président de la république se trouve
placé ce matin
aujourd'hui plus exactement devant un
choix difficile puisque après le vote
des sénateurs cette nuit et celui des
députés dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi
vote d'un texte identique à la majorité
simple
il manque vingt-et-une voix sur les
suffrages exprimés pour que le projet de
loi puisse passer la barre des 3 5e en
congrès à versailles
en fait donc quatre possibilités se
présentent à monsieur pompidou première
possibilité deux cas il convoque le
congrès à versailles comme prévu au
début de la semaine prochaine mais il
prend le risque que le texte soit
repoussé ces fameuses vingt-et-une voix
qui manquent
deuxième cas le chef de l'état prend son
temps dans l'espoir d'une conjoncture
plus favorable qui lui permettent de
récupérer ces vingt-et-une voix et
peut-être davantage encore
deuxième possibilité monsieur pompidou
comme le lui permet l'article 89 de la
constitution choisi de soumettre le
texte au référendum
mais on peut alors se demander si les
partis politiques d'opposition ne seront
pas tenter de transformer ce référendum
en a un pour ou contre la politique de
monsieur pompidou comme lors du
référendum sur l'euro ce serait de toute
façon une épreuve politique forte
importante et qui risquerait fort de
déplaire aux deux assemblées
enfin troisième possibilité le chef de
l'état peut purement et simplement
retiré son texte considérant que les
votes obtenus tant à l'assemblée qu'au
sénat ne constitue pas une approbation
suffisante du projet de loi et que tout
est remis en question
comme on le voit tout tourne donc autour
de ses 21 suffrages qui manque dans la
corbeille du texte pour qu'il soit
ratifié un grand congrès vingt-et-une
voix 19 qui ont fait défaut à
l'assemblée nationale chez les
réformateurs certes mais aussi dans les
rangs du dr et trois au sénat parmi les
sénateurs de l'union centriste
c'est pendant la visite du président
kossyguine au caire que les israéliens
sont passées à la contre offensive sur
le canal de suez faut-il voir un intérêt
politique en plus de l'intérêt militaire
je le crois les israéliens sont parvenus
à traverser le canal de suez en rompant
les lignes égyptienne a traversé avec
des hommes et du matériel au nord du
grand lac amer et de s'implanter en
territoire égyptien
l'intérêt militaires et certains prendre
toutes les troupes égyptiennes à revers
détruire les rampes de missiles placées
le long du canal de suez et enfin
désorganisé l'arrière et surtout établir
une tête de pont israéliennes en
territoires égyptiens ses troupes
israéliennes qui ont reçu des renforts
dans la nuit ont déjà remportée selon
tel aviv des victoires le général zion
est venu leur rendre visite
le caire annoncent cette incursion la
reconnais mes 2 annonce également que
les troupes égyptiennes sont passées à
la contre offensive et ont détruit une
partie de ses troupes israéliennes
l'intérêt politique est tout aussi
important dans le cas d'un cessez le feu
imposé par les grandes puissances
israël se seraient assurés en quelque
sorte une monnaie d échange les têtes de
pont égyptienne d'un côté sur la rive
est du canal de suez contre la tête de
pont israélienne sur la rive ouest du
canal de suez
l'intérêt psychologique n'est pas à
dédaigner non plus d'une part il s'agit
du sinaï territoires occupés à un désert
absolument inhabitée et de l'autre une
tête de pont en territoire égyptien
c'est à dire une zone fertile et surtout
très peuplée
les combats sont d'une rare violence
dans la presqu'île du sinaï où depuis 48
heures s'affrontent égyptiens et
israéliens dans une gigantesque bataille
de chars les israéliens devaient avant
de lancer leur contre-offensive trouver
une parade au fusil en tissant soccer et
aux missiles anti aériens sam
qu'utilisent les égyptiens
cela semble être fait comment nul ne le
sait peut-être grâce à l'apport de
matériel américain qui depuis deux jours
affluent sur les aérodromes israël
le général diana déclaré hier je le cite
la guerre n'est plus comme le prétendent
certains la sphère d'un mois ou de
quelques semaines
c'est une affaire qui prendra au coût
moins de temps cette bataille que les
journaux arabes qualifie de féroces et
d'obstiné ne tourne pas à l'avantagé des
forces israéliennes rapporte l'agencé du
moyen orient basée au caire
pour l'instant le sort en est à dix
c'est une bataille de chars et
d'artillerie avec l'intervention de
l'aviation
il semble maintenant acquis que
l'aviation israélienne et la maîtrise
totale du ciel l'opération lancée à
l'ouest et du canal de suez n'est pas
étrangère à l'absence de riposte
égyptienne
les appareils israéliens non plus à
redouter les missiles simple qui leur
avait causé tant de pertes les premiers
jours à ce propos d'ailleurs les
services de renseignement américains
viennent de publier des chiffres que je
vous livre israël aurait perdu depuis le
6 octobre
780 chat et 100 avions c'est à dire près
de la moitié de ses blindés et le quart
de son aviation
l'egypte 580 chars et 110 avions c'est à
dire le tiers de ses blindés
et le sixième de son aviation la syrie
680 ch 185 avions plus de la moitié de
ses blindés et son aviation
la guerre que se livrent égyptiens et
israéliens sur le conte du sinaï est un
problème de moyens et de tact beyrouth
le commando fedayin retranché dans la
main que vous m'avez cas depuis hier
s'est rendu en fin de matinée
les brigades spéciales de la police
libanaise ont investi l'immeuble et ont
abattu deux des quatre terroristes et
deux autres se sont rendus en otage
américain été tuées et 64 autres otages
sont sains et saufs chili retour à la
propriété privée la junte militaire a
décidé de restituer donc de
dénationaliser plus de 1000 usine
parallèlement les prix ont été augmentés
de 200 à 400 % et les salaires
quadruples t mais la répression continue
plus de 2000 chiliens seraient réfugiés
dans les ambassades de santiago
la reine elizabeth va devoir modifier
ses cartes de visite elle était jusqu'à
présent
elisabeth la seconde reine du royaume
uni d'australie et de ses autres
royaumes pour les australiens sera
désormais et il habite la seconde rennes
d'australie et le seo trop royaux
c'était le voeu formulé par son père et
celui du parlement australien
à chacun sa fierté
un voyage bien remplie 32 jours de
présentations en amérique du sud et
d'une heure sans une heure de vol près
de quarante mille kilomètres parcourus
voilà le premier bilan du voyage
d'airbus
parti le 15 septembre de toulouse airbus
a d'abord participé au salon
aéronautique brésiliens à sao paulo
avant d'entreprendre une longue tournée
au dessus du continent américain
26 aéroports visiter dans six pays
différents
airbus a transporté deux mille deux
cents passagers au cours de 33 vols de
démonstration beaucoup de commentaires
souvent élogieux d impression favorable
notamment de la part des 55
correspondant de bob à deux dès que cinq
ans un commandant de bord qui ont eu
l'occasion de le prendre en main mais
airbus regagne le vieux continent sans
faire l'objet d'une commande à ce jour
treize appareils sont commandés ferme et
26 sont en option
biréacteur court et moyen courriers
airbus est fabriqué en coopération avec
l'allemagne la grande bretagne l'espagne
et la hollande selon l'aménagement
intérieur il pourra remporter de 230 à
340 passagers et autres caractéristiques
très importante il est l'avion le plus
silencieux de sa génération
la crise de l'eau ou rtf monsieur arthur
conte qui rappelait récemment qui doit
être libre pour être loyale et qu'il
doit servir l'intégrité et l'unité de
l'office et entendu cet après-midi par
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale
de son côté monsieur philippe malaud
déclare ce matin dans une interview au
figaro
c'est vrai qu'il ya certains désaccords
entre monsieur compte et moi-même
désaccord relevant du fonctionnement de
l'office
le ministre de l'information poursuit
monsieur arthur conte est plutôt bon
patron mais le rtf est un milieu
difficile
l'information à l'office doit être
neutre il faut appliquer à la ftf les
techniques modernes de gestion
quatre nouvelles inculpations dans la
sphère du cs de la rue edouard pailleron
deux architectes et deux fonctionnaires
de l'éducation nationale le chef du
service construction de l'académie de
paris et son adjoint hier le juge
sablayrolles avait inculpé les pdg des
deux sociétés qui avaient construit le
cef d'autres inculpations pourraient
intervenir dans les prochains jours
inquiétude chez les agriculteurs michel
de bâtisses le président de la fnsea
demande audience à monsieur georges
pompidou
d'après la fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles quatre
secteurs sont en difficulté le lait la
viande les fruits et légumes et le sud
la fnsea réclame des mesures d'urgence
boeing spéciale ce matin au bourget mais
on a préféré la zone de fret au salon
d'honneur pour embarquer vers shanghai
50 passagers sans passeport 50 charolais
de source autorisée on estime que ces
échanges aideront à une meilleure
compréhension entre les cheptels
français et chinois
prochaine livraison début janvier et des
contacts sont pris avec les
représentants de la race limousine
à
grande première en france une
organisation l'institut national de la
consommation a fait une radioscopie
complète de six voitures européennes
pendant un an quatre voitures françaises
la r12 à 204 estime qu en ce sens et la
ga tous 120 et de voiture étrangère la
fiat 128 elop et la skoda ont été
examinés détaillé contrôler et conduite
sur 20000 km un banc d'essai sans
complaisance pour les constructeurs
français
les résultats sont que c'est la renault
zoé est là et la fiat qui sortent en
tête de ce test au point de vue rapport
qualité prix
mais je le répète en fonction des basses
que nous avons prises pour faire cet
essai est que la voiture qui sort grande
perdante de ce dans cette affaire c'est
la 204 peugeot à l'origine de ce
classement trois tests en trop la
sécurité freinage possibilité
dépassements et tenue de route
le coût d'entretien sur 20000 km petits
voitures coûtent en moyenne 3000 francs
dernier grand domaine rarement abordé la
pollution je mets pas en cause deux
constructeurs de voitures si je les ai
mis en cause puisque comme monsieur
poujade l'a dit lui-même qu'il mettait
au huitième rang de leurs préoccupations
les critères qui pour nous aucune
importance extraordinaire notamment le
critère de la pollution et que je pense
qu'à l'intérieur d'une voiture se trouve
souvent des gadgets ou des dés comment
dirais-je des éléments et qui sont
d'abord j'ai indiscutable lorsqu'un choc
peut se produire
parmi les éléments dangereux les
rétroviseurs les points d'ancrage de la
ceinture les commandes saillantes les
réservoirs d'essence exposé au chant
critique importante car le mauvais
emplacement d'une commande
visibilité restreinte sont souvent à
l'origine d'accidents mortels ces
voitures ne constitue pas alors j'ai en
elle-même bien sûr puisque il ne s'agit
pas de les faire retirer de la
circulation comme une voiture qui avait
été définie comme étant très dangereuse
aux états unis par le raf nader en
général les voitures progressent de
manière satisfaisante dans notre pays
qui en a qui progresse c'est évidemment
plus ou moins vite ça dépend aussi de
l'ancienneté de leur conception
mais cela ne signifie pas qu'ils ne
fallait pas faire des progrès très
considérable en fonction des accidents
qui se produisent toutes les semaines
sur les routes et en fonction aussi il
faut bien le dire de la mauvaise
éducation du conducteur français quand
il est au volant
il ne s'agit pas de comparer
l'initiative de 50 me au consommateur la
croisade américaine de ralph nader
contre la general motors
toutefois les constructeurs français
devraient suivre de très près les
résultats de ce banc d'essai l'objectif
reste avant tout d'avertir et de
défendre les consommateurs
les constructeurs sont satisfaits le
vélo français se porte bien
2 millions de cycles vendus en 1972
compte un million à 60 phénomènes
économiques inattendue à une époque où
la voiture submerge nos routes et nos
campagnes
à cela plusieurs risques la première
remonte à 1968 époque pendant laquelle
la crainte d'une pénurie d'essence a
fait démarrer les ventes du site
la deuxième vient des usa l'exemple
d'ailleurs est venu d'en haut
le président eisenhower soi même sur les
conseils de son médecin a enfourché la
bicyclette à la suite d'un infarctus et
bien sûr les américains on suit
actuellement la france exporte le quart
de sa production aux états unis
enfin la vie sédentaire les difficultés
de la circulation la pollution le besoin
d' espaces verts ont poussé les français
à redécouvrir la visiter la france se
trouve aujourd'hui au cinquième rang des
constructeurs après les états unis le
japon l'urss et l'allemagne de l'ouest
alors qu'en 68 12 % de la production
était exportée c'est près de la moitié
soit 46% qui est parti en 72 sur les
routes de l'étranger
un nouveau venu dans la clientèle
française le japon qui a acheté cette
année plus de 22000 bicyclette chiffres
apparemment dérisoire mais 80 fois
supérieure à celui de 1960
ces résultats soulignent la vitalité de
l'industrie us
bref matériel sportif il ya quelques
années
le vélo est devenu aujourd'hui symbole
de détente moyen de locomotion agréable
si l'on se réfère aux statistiques très
officiel pratiquement un décès sur deux
dans le monde est imputable aux maladies
du coeur se dire l'importance capitale
des recherches qui sont effectués en
permanence un peu partout pour tenter
d'apporter sinon une guérison du moins
une amélioration chez les malades
cette guerre permanente livré aux
maladies de coeur va s'exprimer
publiquement à partir de lundi prochain
avec le départ de ce que l'on appelle la
semaine du coeur 1973 c'est ainsi qu'à
partir du 22 lundi prochain donc une
carte du coeur pourra être acheté par le
public une carte utile dans les deux
sens puisque le prix de sa vente 3
francs ira alimenter les recherches et
elle constituera cette carte pour
l'acquéreur une véritable carte
d'identification médicale l'un des
aspects de la lutte contre les maladies
de coeur c'est la greffe autour de
laquelle une certaine polémique est
engagée depuis quelques temps à noter à
cet égard la prise de position hier soir
du professeur dubost qui estime les
transplantations cardiaques prématuré
toujours tant que le phénomène de rejet
n'aura pas été vaincue mais ce n'est là
je vous le disais que l'un des aspects
de la lutte contre les maladies de coeur
dont nous allons parler maintenant
beaucoup plus en détail avec le
professeur michel de georges et notre
spécialiste médical pierre bouchet
professeur une question d'abord je crois
qu'il va résumer l'ensemble j'ai 35 ans
je mesure 1 m 76
je paie 74 kg je ne fume plus depuis
quelques mois
j'ai le coeur apparemment solide
beaucoup de français sont dans mon cas
et avec l'âge que j'ai cela dit est ce
que je suis en danger
fort heureusement est pour vous non car
les facteurs de risque comme l'ont dit
pour vous sont très réduits il y en a un
c'est que nous appartenons au sexe
masculin et alors ça c'est
automatiquement un facteur de risque
puisque les femmes au moins jusqu'à 40
50 ans échappe à cette catégorie là de
maladies de coeur c'est à dire un
infarctus à l'insuffisance coronaire
aimez vous avez vous avez vous des
facteurs des éléments très favorables
d'abord vous avez laissé fumer alors là
c'est un acquis considérable et pour
persévérer dans cette voie
tout peut vous encourager je crois que
c'est très important
ensuite votre poids est satisfaisant il
n'y a pas de visite et je suppose que
vous
vérifier au passage vous n'est pas trop
de cholestérol n'est pas trop de sucre
dans le sang vidal et propre graisse
dans le sang
notre régime alimentaire est
raisonnablement coordonnées et mon dieu
pour peu que vous preniez un peu
d'exercice il tentait que les charges de
la télévision vous en laisse le loisir
et bien je crois que vous êtes dans de
bonnes conditions pour affronter au
mieux les années à venir
un point encore vos parents en
excellente santé malgré un âge assez
avancé
alors ça c'est un très bon point pouvait
rien mais c'est un très bon point est ce
que vous pouvez c'est persévérer dans la
voie actuelle et comme ça je crois que
vous aborderez au mieux la période
critique qui n'est pas encore pour vous
mais la période critique c'est eux pour
l'homme pour ce genre de maladie c'est à
partir de la cinquantaine
après la période la plus critique vis à
bourges et venez pas encore lui-même
dans l'intérêt de ce n'était pas pour le
moment mais je voulais vous poser y
arrivions nous nous la verrons toutes
les façons avec sourire la question qui
se pose est quand même importante parmi
les facteurs de risque que vous avez
cité le tabac et vous avez indiqué en
même temps que les femmes étaient moins
sujettes à l'infarctus que les hommes
or dans le monde moderne il semble que
la consommation en tabac des femmes
c'est à dire ce facteur de risque
rejoint celle des hommes alors comment
pouvez-vous m'expliquer que les femmes
malgré qu'elle fut malgré qu'elle soit
parfois obèses souvent diabétiques etc
comment expliquez vous que malgré tous
ces risques accumulé semblables aux
nôtres elles fassent moins d'infarctus
il ya trois éléments d'abord parce que
ce qui est des causes de l'infarctus ce
n'est pas un seul facteur mais c'est une
accumulation d'une série de facteurs
il y en a pour lesquelles nous ne
pouvons pas grand chose ils nous sont
donnés à la base il y en a sur lesquels
nous pouvons agir comme le tap halle des
sports etc
donc c'est toujours dit sion ou une
multiplication de diverses causes qui
finalement est responsable de
l'infarctus pour la femme pour le tabac
pour l'inde l'une de ses causes
les femmes rejoignent la consommation de
tabac masculine mais ne rejoigne plus de
même que progressivement et enfin et
vous avez mille fois raison de le dire
il ya fondamentalement quelque chose de
différent
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ce quelque
chose de différent et bien c'est là l'un
des
voies de recherche et quand on fait des
recherches sur les maladies les artères
sur l'athérosclérose
on n'essaie pas 6 aimant de cerner ce
qui fait ces différences de cet ordre là
il est bien probable il est certain que
en l'occurrence c'est lié aux glandes
que l'on dit en de krynn qui secrète un
certain nombre de choses à l'organisme
et qui font finalement que la femme les
différentes de l'homme et elle est
surtout différente de l'homme jusqu'à la
ménopause puisque vous le savez comme
moi
au delà c'est à dire vers 60 voire 70
ans la marque us alors comment je
commence à toucher la femme à peu près
dans la même proportion club nous avons
amené ici et je pense que c'est
important un coeur qui est reproduit un
petit peu le coeur humain
ce choeur eux moi j'ai fait un petit
calcul c'est que de la naissance à 65
ans ce coeur que vous voyez bas 3
milliards deux cent trois millions cinq
cent mille fois et assure la cadence de
3 litres et demi deux cents par minute
et par mètre carré de surface corporelle
le débit de 145 millions suis 100
millilitres de sang voilà la vie d'un
coeur humain
ce choeur a besoin de sang lui-même pour
fonctionner et voici les coronaires
alors qu'est ce qui se passe quand il y
a en gym de poitrine coronary tu es
infarctus vous nous l'expliquer les
chiffres que vous venez dire sont
impressionnants sont impressionnants ils
sont toutes au crédit de cette petite
pompe qui au fond n'est pas lourde dans
l'organisme le mieux reste lourd ça
dépend de la proportion d'individus un
vrai coeur est à peu près de cette
taille 6 août à peu près de settat si ça
n'est pas très gros si vous pensez à la
performance de la pompe que ça assure or
ceux ci s'est construit pour battre 100
ans
en gros une garantie formelle mais s'est
construit en gros pour battre cent ans
alors l'important c'est qu'on le fasse
rien qui altèrent ou qui empêchent cette
performance
l'une des maladies il y en a d'autres
bien entendu mais l'une des maladies qui
altèrent cette performance c'est ce
qu'on appelle la maladie les artères et
savait qu'elle ne touche pas uniquement
le coeur et touche aussi les artères du
cerveau elle touche aussi les artères de
jambes mais elle touche aussi les
artères du coeur c'est à dire ce que
peut être vous voyez bien là ce sont ces
artères qui tourne plutôt autour du
coeur
il y en a deux et qui permette rocker
qui est un muscle qui bat de recevoir le
ravitaillement dont il a besoin
avec le sens c'est-à-dire les
constituants du sang le sucre les corps
gras et aussi l'oxygène
si la maladie des artères bush
ces vaisseaux à ce moment là le musc du
coeur ne reçoit plus sa ration normal il
souffre il souffre et il exprime ceci
par la fatigue et l'expriment ceci par
la douleur si on va plus loin et si au
lieu de cesser en partie ou
momentanément cette halal sans au lieu
de cesser momentanément d'arrivée
cessent totalement alors à ce moment-là
le muscle est atteint et ne fonctionne
plus du tout ya ce qu'on appelle très
communément une lésion cardiaque ce qui
correspond si vous voulez en première
approche l'infarctus
alors pour vous poser une question aux
simples comment peut-on faire pour
éviter précisément de ses artères se
bouche et ne donne pas au coeur le
centre il a besoin
alors il faut prévenir les maladies les
artères où dès qu'elles se manifestent
les traités et ceci est tout à fait
important car l'un des bus de la
fondation nationale de cardiologie d'un
début de la campagne que nous menons la
semaine prochaine c'est d'aider les
cardiaques bien entendu c'est favoriser
les enquêtes ou la recherche dans tel ou
tel secteur de pointe mais c'est aussi
de faire comprendre à chacun plus dans
une certaine mesure il est libre de son
destin qui peut influer sur son destin
et que par conséquent il faut que chacun
sache les signes qui permettent de
déceler de façon très précoce telles
maladies des artères ou du coeur et
aussi les éléments qui permettent de
prévenir et ce sont là deux points sur
lequel on a coeur d'ailleurs avec les
pouvoirs publics nous estimons que
l'éducation sanitaire est tout à fait
indispensable et nous y attachons qu'est
ce qui provoque
des artères les causes les plus
fréquentes les causes les plus
fréquentes des maladies les artères
c'est ce qu'on appelle d'athérosclérose
latéraux mme ce sont ces artères qui
s'épaississent et qui se bouche et
écossais l'augmentation des lippi
l'écossé le tabac l'écossé tous ces
facteurs de rials de diabète pas
l'alcool directement
incidemment peut-être ce sont tous ces
facteurs de risque et qu'il faut déceler
très tôt et c'est pourquoi nous disions
hier la prévention et toute la fuite
importante est ce que vous pourriez
donner sur le plan concret parce que les
gens se paye souvent d'avoir mal au
coeur alors ils craignent quelque chose'
payan tiens mon coeur s'emballe oui j'ai
une douleur dans l'épaule
est ce que vous pouvez dire avec
précision à chacun d'entre nous si vous
ressentez tel type de douleur
précisément attention allez tout de
suite à l'hôpital parce que vous risquez
un infarctus
je crois que ceci est facile et capitale
c'est capital parce que l'infarctus du
myocarde est une maladie qui reste grave
malgré nos efforts qui est grave surtout
dans les premières heures et ils se
trouvent les statistiques que l'on a
fait montre que les malades n'en prenne
conscience n'atteigne le médecin que
vera 5e la sixième heure que il appelle
une ambulance que vers la onzième heure
que ils se font hospitaliser que le
lendemain
or c'est dans cette période là dans les
premières heures et les premiers jours
que l'on peut agir il faut donc qu'ils
soient que les patients éventuel soit en
alerte et les signes d' alerte d'un
trouble des maladies des coronaires
d'une insuffisance coronaire de l'angine
de poitrine
bien entendu s'il s'agit d'une jeune
femme de 20 ans il n'y a pas de risque
par conséquent elle n'aura pas des
douleurs comme ça où ces gens là ce sont
de fausses douleur ou autre chose
ceci est surtout important chez l'homme
deux visions celui qui est exposé c'est
à dire l'homme à partir de la
cinquantaine quelquefois aussi à partir
de la quarantaine est ce que d'autres
douleurs ne peuvent pas s'il est celle
qui est qui annonce un parc plus il y a
dans le coeur il ya des douleurs
d'origine nerveuse ils n'ont pas ces
caractères aussi net que ce que je viens
de dire ce sont donc les fausses angine
de poitrine qui en effet sont légion
parce qu'on boit un peu trop de café
parce que l'on s'énerve un peu parce que
l'on se querellent un peu
alors on éprouve les phénomènes un peu
désagréable mais qui n'ont pas cessé
caractère absolument nette et qui par
conséquent permettre au contraire de le
rassurer mais un monsieur le professeur
merci d'être venu avec nous je pense que
c'est un problème très important nous
aurons l'occasion de reparler de cette
semaine du coeur 1973 merci d'être venu
sur notre plateau je vous rappelle aussi
avant d'aller rejoindre gérard vidal ans
à la bourse de paris que vous pourrez
voir ce soir à 21h30
notre émission plein cadre l'émission de
grands reportages de 24 heures sur la
une au sommaire le portrait d'un
officier de carrière de l'armée
française
il répond en toute franchise à nos
questions sur le métier des armes le
sens de sa vie le rôle et la place de
l'armée aujourd'hui en france
et puis un document dans ce plan cadre
une interview exclusive du général peron
et de sa femme isabelle ita à 60 18 ans
juan peron est depuis octobre chef de
l'état argentin et cela pour la
troisième fois donc plein cadre ce soir
21h30
nous allons maintenant rejoindre à la
bourse de paris gérard vidalenc
bien que bolelli nous allons parler tout
de suite de la rente pinay puisque ça a
été la grande semaine de la reprise des
cotations de la rente
on s'est maintenus pratiquement au cours
de la veille 260 avec un marché
extrêmement que mûri il y en a encore
fait près de 100 millions donc en trois
jours 300 millions et 30 milliards dans
ces enfants c'est vous dire l'ampleur du
marché
là je pense que 1 260 la baisse ne peut
plus poursuivre car tout de même on est
à peu près à 20% du la valeur réelle du
nouvel emprunt giscard puisque la valeur
de remboursement vers le 15 novembre
sera de 330 francs donc je pense
qu'après une période d'adaptation et les
gens comprendront qu évidemment ils
n'ont pas intérêt à se précipiter pour
vendre bien au contraire
en ce qui concerne la rente pinay
d'ailleurs et vous voyez que les mines
d'or en baisser tout à l'heure sur votre
écran est apparu le prix du napoléon en
légère baisse
ceci peut-être en raison des espoirs
bien timide de cessez le feu au
proche-orient et entendu cette petite
baisse technique sur l'or peut avoir une
influence sur la tenue de la rente pinay
m'enfin tout de même l'essentiel c'est
de rappeler que la valeur de
remboursement
vers la fin du mois de novembre est de
330 francs la valeur de reprise
exactement la bourse de paris est
horizontale aujourd'hui les valeurs
françaises répète pratiquement leurs
cours de la veille
ce qui est tout de même un signe très
bon puisque si cette relative stabilité
se maintient c'est que le marché
finalement ne demande qu'à monter et je
pense que là aussi sans multiplier les
prévisions pour la semaine prochaine
eh bien on devrait être certainement
meilleur os
encore une fois de petrofina la grande
affaire belge avec eux dans laquelle
d'ailleurs il ya des traits d'importants
capitaux français près de 20% du capital
de petrochina est entre les mains des
français à monter la valeur a beaucoup
monté encore aujourd'hui saint gobain
annonce des résultats très brillant pour
le premier semestre
en effet l'augmentation du bénéfice est
de l'ordre de 41 % pour un chiffre
d'affaires en augmentation de 18% on
peut dire que maintenant vraiment saint
gobain donnent tous ses fruits depuis la
réorganisation du groupe du côté de
pechiney à noguères la remise en route
finalement de l' usine d'aluminium et
plus rapide qu'on le pensait puisque à
ce jour 60 % la capacité de production
de l'usiné maintenant atteint et on
pense que fin novembre cette capacité
pour être de rejoindre environ 75%
sauf accident voyez tout de même qu'il y
à quelques reprises quelques points
gagnés sur un certain nombre de valeurs
je pense que si le marché s'anime et un
peu plus il y aurait une confirmation de
la reprise dont je vous parlais il ya un
astre sur de vindelle encore des gains
aujourd'hui la société va disparaître et
remplacée par une société financière
sacilor voici maintenant les
performances des six cas depuis le début
de l'année les six cas qui sont proposés
par les banques
voyez que des résultats des scores très
intéressant tout de même ont été
réalisés silva france crédit lyonnais
avec un gain de près de 13% ce qui est
remarquable puisque depuis le début de
l'année la bourse a connu quand même une
période agitée et parent unis c'est là
le crédit agricole une valeur la bnp et
interselection la société générale voilà
pour la bourse de paris avoue que les
brevets merci cette édition se termine
je vous remercie de l'avoir suivi avec
nous au nom de toute l'équipe de 24
heures sur la lune et je vous donne
rendez vous ce soir à 19h45 bonne après
midi au revoir